Trascrizione: Sarah Masella
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Quanto la forza incide nella nostra vita?
Ciascuno di noi usa,
ogni giorno, tantissima forza:
fisica, emotiva, intellettuale.
È una forza che fa parte di noi,
che ci accompagna
da quando ci alziamo alla mattina
A quando andiamo a letto la sera.
Ed è una forza che si fortifica
e si moltiplica,
grazie alle sinergie con gli altri,
grazie all'empatia collettiva,
che ha la capacità di annullare
le distanze fisiche e sociali
e di ridurre il senso
di solitudine individuale.
E questa è una forza che noi usiamo
delle nostre attività
quotidiane più spicciole;
ma la utilizziamo, anche,
quando dobbiamo affrontare
sfide impegnative e importanti.
Allora pensate, cosa succede
quando questa forza viene contrastata
da una forza di segno uguale e contrario
che invece di sorreggerci, di sostenerci,
mira a distruggerci
e si scaglia contro di noi
proprio quando siamo
più indifesi, più inermi?
Ed è una forza che spesso proviene
da chi dovrebbe amarci,
da chi dovrebbe proteggerci,
cui affidiamo le nostre
debolezze, fragilità,
e che invece usa quella forza
non in modo positivo
ma come un macigno
per spingerci sempre più giù?
È la forza della violenza.
Tutti noi leggiamo, ogni giorno,
fatti di cronaca, di violenza
perpetrata nei confronti di uomini,
di donne, di bambini, di animali;
però non sappiamo veramente
che cos'è la violenza,
almeno fino a quando
non ci tocca da vicino,
fino a quando non l'assorbiamo
attraverso la pelle,
non penetra nelle nostre ossa,
non ne percepiamo il gusto e il sapore.
Si dice che l'uomo, in fondo,
è caratterizzato per sua natura
da prevaricazione e aggressività.
Ma d'altronde, noi non fummo fatti
per essere come bruti
ma per vivere in società,
per vivere insieme.
E allora, qual è la prima regola
per una convivenza civile?
Rispettarsi gli uni con gli altri,
la cosiddetta regola del neminem laedere.
Ossia, la mia libertà finisce
là dove inizia la tua.
E allora, dove nasce la violenza?
La violenza nasce
quando quel confine viene oltrepassato
senza il consenso dell'altro,
in modo prevaricatore:
in modo, appunto, violento.
Ma che cosa possiamo fare, noi,
per contrastare la violenza, per evitarla,
per prevenirla, per distruggerla?
I modi ci sono, le soluzioni pure.
Però, prima, bisogna capire
dove nasce la violenza.
La violenza nasce
nei rapporti tra le persone,
nasce perché esistono
i legami tra gli esseri umani,
quei rapporti interpersonali
di affetto, di amicizia,
di sentimenti, di lavoro,
in cui ciascuno di noi
esplica la sua personalità
e che rappresentano le fondamenta
sulla cui base noi costruiamo
la nostra dignità e la nostra autostima.
Infatti, quando si parla di violenza,
solitamente si tende a considerarla
esclusivamente come una violenza fisica.
In realtà c'è un altro tipo di violenza,
tanto grave e ancora più subdola:
è la violenza psicologica.
Avreste mai pensato, voi,
che una frase come "Tu sei mia"
in qualche modo potrebbe caratterizzare
un animo possessivo e prevaricatore?
Oppure "Non hai bisogno
degli altri. Ci sono io".
"Preferisci i tuoi amici a me".
O ancora, "Non metterti così scollata".
"A chi stai scrivendo?".
"Perché non rispondi
alle mie telefonate?".
"Non volevo, era solo un ceffone,
ma è colpa tua, perché
mi hai fatto arrabbiare".
"Se tu facessi quello che ti dico,
non sarei costretto a picchiarti".
"Ti avevo detto di obbedirmi.
E non l'hai fatto".
Ecco queste sono tutta una serie
di frasi, le prime ovviamente,
perché le ultime testimoniano e confermano
una violenza fisica già perpetrata,
che se presi singolarmente, se dette
in modo occasionale o estemporaneo,
non rappresentano violenza.
La violenza viene rappresentata
quando queste frasi vengono dette
ripetutamente e sistematicamente,
in un'escalation
che fa passare queste espressioni
come espressioni d'amore
quando in realtà simulano
un atteggiamento, o una personalità,
prevaricatrice.
Abbiamo parlato di violenza,
di violenza dei rapporti interpersonali;
e abbiamo detto che non riguarda soltanto
l'aspetto sentimentale dei rapporti,
ma può riguardare
anche l'aspetto di lavoro.
La violenza anche in ambito lavorativo.
Gina Stella gestiva con la sorella
una comunità per gli ex detenuti
ammessi al lavoro esterno.
Una notte Gina Stella è stata sequestrata,
è stata portata in un luogo isolato,
dove è stata accoltellata
e violentata per ore
da uno di questi ex detenuti.
Il suo aggressore poi l'ha lasciata
in un fossato, inerme:
Gina Stella ha subito il crimine
che a mio avviso
è più grave per una donna.
Io lo chiamo omicidio dell'anima.
Il nostro Codice Penale
lo chiama violenza sessuale.
Gina Stella porta ancora oggi,
a distanza di anni,
le cicatrici nell'animo,
sulle gambe, sul torace, sul collo,
di quelle violenze, di quella notte.
Ma lei, proprio attraverso
quelle cicatrici,
attraverso i punti di sutura
che hanno cucito le sue ferite,
è riuscita a rinascere,
è riuscita a ricostruire una vita
laddove quella vita
era completamente sbriciolata
e si era completamente annullata.
E c'è riuscita grazie
alla sua forza interiore
e grazie, anche, a una grande famiglia
come l'Osservatorio Nazionale
Sostegno Vittime
nella quale Gina Stella combatte
perché altre donne non abbiano a patire
la tortura, le violenze
e la sofferenza che ha patito lei.
La storia di Gina Stella è emblematica,
perché ci fa capire come,
attraverso la condivisione
della nostra sofferenza,
attraverso l'aiuto e le risposte
ai bisogni degli altri,
è possibile ricostruirsi una vita
laddove quella vita
sembrava completamente distrutta.
Ma quindi, questa forza per combattere
la violenza dove la possiamo trovare?
Dentro di noi, ma anche fuori.
Il nostro sistema legislativo,
siamo uno stato di diritto,
garantisce strumenti
a chi subisce gravi reati.
Penso per esempio al codice rosso,
che dà la possibilità
a chi denuncia atti persecutori,
maltrattamenti in famiglia
o violenza sessuale,
di essere riascoltato
nelle 72 ore dopo la denuncia
allo scopo di verificare la necessità
di assumere provvedimenti
limitativi della libertà
nei confronti della persona denunciata.
Ma penso anche alla prevenzione,
alla cultura della prevenzione.
Perché mai dobbiamo
accettare prevaricazioni
né di natura psicologica,
né di natura fisica.
E dobbiamo insegnare
ai nostri bambini, fin da piccoli,
la cultura del rispetto,
dato e preteso.
E penso ancora che la forza
si trovi dell'indipendenza:
indipendenza non solo economica,
che è importantissima,
ma anche indipendenza mentale,
culturale, indipendenza sessuale.
Perché la libertà non dev'essere
considerato come un concetto,
un concetto negativo di ribellione
a quello che è un sistema
di regole imposto;
ma dev'essere considerato, invece,
come un riconoscimento pieno
dei nostri valori
e dei diritti e dei doveri che abbiamo
in ambito personale, affettivo,
lavorativo, sociale.
Ecco: oggi noi abbiamo parlato
di tanti concetti,
abbiamo affrontato tanti concetti:
il concetto della forza,
il concetto della violenza;
e delle soluzioni:
la prevenzione, l'indipendenza.
E questi sono concetti
che fanno parte, tutti,
di quel meraviglioso
contenitore che è la vita,
che viene arricchito
dall'esperienza di ognuno di noi
e dall'approccio con cui ciascuno di noi
affronta sfide e opportunità,
in un percorso di vita
che da individuale diventa collettivo.
Perché è proprio la forza collettiva
capace di includere ciò che è costruttivo
ed escludere ciò che è distruttivo,
che può creare quel guscio
di protezione indispensabile
per una società sana,
nella quale ognuno di noi
riconosce se stesso negli altri,
e non grazie agli altri.
Perché noi abbiamo valore
in base al valore
che noi diamo a noi stessi,
e non in base al valore esclusivo
che ci viene riconosciuto dagli altri.
Ognuno di noi ha il dovere etico e morale
di aiutare gli altri,
perché gli altri siamo noi;
e se ognuno di noi trasmette
la sua forza positiva agli altri,
allora sì che potremo dire
che la forza della vita
vincerà sulla forza della violenza.
Grazie.
(Applausi)